à cannes au festival la réalité c'est du
cinéma
aujourd'hui le metteur en scène jean luc
godard a reçu en effet une tarte à la
crème en pleine figure de la part de
quelqu'un qui n'avait pas apprécié la
nudité de la sainte vierge dans son film
je vous salue marie de cannes
notre envoyé spécial france roche
sur l'escalator qui le conduit à la
projection de son film détective jean
luc godard très calme ne sait pas ce qui
l'attend attention une tarte à la crème
en pleine figure il a bien pris la chose
l'assaillant sophie
deux heures plus tard commentaire
gags et toi il aimerait voir et
le croyait que la tarte à la crème vous
êtes dirigé contre nous à les
intégristes du film mais je ne peux pas
dire c'est un peu ça c'est là la presse
et les médias qui fabrique un événement
non content on n'est plus des êtres
humains en aide et on est des moments de
d'un événement préfabriqués et voilà
tout donc sa fin
un peu peur on peut s'en sortir et que
nous ans est là qu il ya des endroits où
des époques où
sors pas avec nous détective johnny
hallyday lundi j'ai vu le film deux fois
que je vois une troisième fois pour
comprendre quelle impression ça vous
fait d'entendre parler de 10 ans lui a
fait dire vers la famille
parce que vous croyez qu'il a appris ça
par coeur avant la pause et une question
il est forcé de répondre fameux par vous
croyez qu'il a compris et alliés
devraient rien à comprendre